[Applaudissements]
nous la vérité
il ya des trucs qui te font chier les
trucs que tu t'es jamais en promo des
trucs salto arrière
le problème c'est que ce soit contre
vient vendre ta musique même en chine
mais même faire de la ville c c'est à
dire c'est une aventure humaine et dans
son coup tu te retrouves ta à l'emprunt
sort un peu du porte-à-porte quoi toi
mais à un moment donné tu étais de
l'intérieur a dit il ya un discours qui
s'inscrit et puis voilà quoi
et puis comme ben par rapport à ce
rythme là on fait du généraliste corse a
donc servi attention l'interview qui
vient la c1 car notre je sais pas quoi
c'est ce que perçoit sur les attachés de
presse et là tu as tu as une vieille
fille qui arrive et qui dit je vais vous
poser les mêmes questions que tout le
monde donc il ya un animateur tu peux
pas blairer chez qui tirait pas une
émission à quel tir épaules tu trouves
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi c'est les corps c'est pour
vous c'est mon corps alors on va
acquérir quelqu'un qui joue gros ce soir
ils jouent et 28 mai morandini excusez
moi je vais me permettre un truc c'est
ma chronique la mort on dit tu la
morandini le destin mais non je ne vois
là tu es tu es morandini je me rendis
joker voilà eh ben vous aimez morandini
est fausse a alors cogné sur la même
radio ma perspective
mes grands blocs te fasse
[Rires]